en bolivia el gobierno de luisa se ha
tomado la decisión de dejar en suspenso
la obligatoriedad de portar el carnet de
vacunación hasta el 26 de enero debido a
que los centros de vacunación se han
visto rebasados de gente que quería
adquirir una dosis para tener en sus
manos este carnet que era obligatorio
desde el primero de enero en paralelo'
diferentes sectores sociales que apoyan
al movimiento al socialismo es decir al
partido de gobierno han rechazado el
decreto que dispone la obligatoriedad de
este pase sanitario e incluso han pedido
al gobierno de luis arse que destituya a
los ministros que lo han puesto en
vigencia pues están en contra de este
carnet pero también en contra de la
vacunación hay que recordar que en
bolivia una gran parte de la población
se ha negado a vacunarse ya sea por
creencias mitos o por desinformación el
gobierno ha señalado que esto no es un
retroceso en su medida y que solamente
quiere dar tiempo para que la gente
pueda concurrir a los centros de
vacunación sin aglomeración para obtener
sus dosis respectivas hasta el 26 de
enero fecha en la que entraría en
vigencia nuevamente el decreto sin
embargo estos sectores sociales que se
oponen han dicho que no van a permitir
que este decreto se mantenga